foreign
[Music]
I'm Cameron mirvald I'm an assistant
professor of molecular biology at
Princeton University and my lab develops
crispr-based Technologies for detecting
viruses and today I'm going to tell you
a bit more about that
so to start I just want to spend a brief
moment and motivate the problem so there
are a lot of different situations where
we might want to detect viruses as the
last few years have really shown Us in
in red on this graph I've highlighted
the majority of places where viral
detection used to take place that is to
say for the most part we used to detect
viruses in doctors offices or when
people were sick in hospitals now over
the past few years we've seen a growth
towards self-testing and drive-through
testing highlighted in blue on the slide
however what we really need in the long
run to be successful is to expand
testing to a wider variety of scenarios
outlined in purple these include testing
at the workplace the airport in a school
or even a stadium now that's not going
to be super easy as I've sort of
outlined in the graph in particular this
graph is organized with the x-axis as
the turnaround time that is how fast a
result is needed and the y-axis is the
batch size that is how many tests need
to be performed now as you can probably
imagine it's not as easy to perform lots
and lots of tests very very quickly but
that's actually what we really need in
order to be successful in this purple
quadrant of
and so our goal is to really develop new
technologies that enable us to move up
and to the right on this graph that is
that enable us to perform more and more
tests more and more quickly to give us
the answers we need
now to do that
we use the crispr system
now let me just give you a brief
background about what crispr is and how
it works
so crispr is this amazing system that
bacteria use to defend themselves
against bacteriophages which are viruses
that infect bacteria
the crispr system consists of this set
of repeat and spacer sequences indicated
by an r and an s on the graphic on the
slide
and that crispr array gets transcribed
when one of these DNA or RNA viruses
infects a bacteria
and then that transcript gets processed
into these guide rnas which then can
recognize the DNA of the invading RNA or
DNA virus via complementary base pairing
and that's usually done with the help of
an effector protein that both helps with
the base pairing and then also provides
catalytic activity to cleave the
invading nucleic acid
and so a very canonical example of this
is the crispr effector protein cas9
which Cleaves double-stranded DNA
complementary to a guide RNA
and cas9 is really has really
revolutionized the study of DNA via Gene
editing and numerous other applications
but I'm actually not going to talk about
cas9 today
and we'll be talking about cast 13. what
you can basically think of as the RNA
targeting equivalent of cas9
and so sort of like cas9 cache 13 uses a
guide RNA to detect particular sequences
but those sequences are single stranded
RNA rather than double-stranded DNA and
there are a couple of important
technical distinctions between cast 13
and cos9 as well so one key difference
is that cost 13 has a longer spacer
sequence which is that sequence that
directs the guide RNA and cost 13 to the
Target RNA
um and then finally uh cost 13 has both
CIS and trans cleavage activity that is
when cash 13 binds to its Target it
becomes activated and it can cleave the
Target and other rnas in solution many
many times and that's in contrast to
cas9 which binds to its Target and cuts
The Target just once
and it turns out that trans cleavage
activity is something we're going to
harness in a few slides for detection
purposes but I'll get into that more
in a moment
now I just want to take a brief moment
and and point out to you that I think
cas13 has similar potential to cas9 but
for the study of RNA and there are a
number of different applications
outlined on this slide we can use cost
13 to both measure and perturb RNA
either by Imaging or or by a nucleic
acid detection and we can also use it to
modify to cleave to degrade RNA and I
think that's super exciting for the rest
of this talk though what we're going to
focus on is this nucleic acid detection
application of cache 13 I'll kind of get
into a bit more about how that works and
how we've used it in a bunch of new and
exciting
so how does one use cas13 to detect
nucleic acids well
um as I mentioned earlier we take
advantage of that collateral cleavage of
cast 13. so what happens as Illustrated
on this slide is that cash 13 and the
crispr RNA bind to a Target RNA sequence
that then activates the enzyme allowing
it to cleave a reporter RNA many many
times
now this reporter RNA is special it
contains a fluorophore and a quencher
connected by a short sequence of RNA
and so what happens is that initially
that reporter is intact and there is no
signal produced because the quencher
quenches the fluorescence
but then once cast 13 binds the Target
and becomes activated it starts to
cleave that reporter and reporter
cleavage produces a fluorescent signal
because it separates the 404 and the
quencher
and what we then see over time is this
accumulation of fluorescent signal upon
recognition of the RNA Target by cash 13
and that is what we're able to detect
now this is really advantageous compared
to a more traditional hybridization
based approach and the reason for that
is that one single specific binding
event with cast 13 and the crispr RNA
can now turn into many many subsequent
cleavage events and so there's this
amplification of signal and also
increase in specificity relative to
hybridization because it's the enzyme
cast 13 that decides when it becomes
activated rather than just the
thermodynamics of nucleic acid
hybridization
all right so that sounds really great
and super exciting but unfortunately
it's not enough on its own to achieve
sensitive nucleic acid detection
um and the reason for that is that on
its own that activity of cash 13
increases performance by about a factor
of a thousand or so
which sounds really great but
unfortunately that's not enough to
detect really really small quantities of
nucleic acids that you typically find in
patients who are infected with viruses
and so in order to take that fundamental
class 13 detection reaction and make it
uh achieve clinically relevant
sensitivities we need to do a couple of
Upstream steps and this uh a method for
doing this was developed uh uh by our
colleagues in functions lab
um and it's called Sherlock and the way
Sherlock works is at the very end is
this nucleic acid detection step that I
outlined on the previous slide
however
there are some key Upstream steps and we
start with an input sample which could
come from an infected patient or an
animal or the environment we then
extract the nucleic acids from that
sample we perform amplification to
increase the amount of nucleic acids in
the sample and then we in vitro
transcribed that double-stranded
Amplified DNA and convert it into RNA
that can be detected using cost 13.
uh we do that in vitro transcription
typically using t7 RNA polymerase and
we've encoded
um a promoter for that polymerase in one
of the amplification primers so it
really is relatively seamless but it
does involve these key additional steps
um and again that's really to enhance
the sensitivity and relative uh uh to
detection alone to get down to to being
able to detect very very small
quantities of nucleic acid
all right
so we and others have used Sherlock for
a variety of different nucleic acid uh
applications now I'm just highlighting a
few examples on the slide here
um so in one example we used Sherlock to
detect uh Dengue in infected patient
saliva using a visual readout you can
see there's a test line that forms in
the presence of infection with Dengue
much like a pregnancy test that is not
present in a healthy saliva sample
but we can also do other things like
detect a single nucleotide polymorphisms
or Snips this is done using a pair of
crispr rnas one of which targets the
wild type or non-mutated sequence and
the other which targets the mutant
sequence and by measuring the
differential activity of those crispr
rnas we can tell if a mutation is
present or not in a sample
we can also do non-invasive detection
from a variety of different bodily
fluids including saliva but also things
like urine and these are are
particularly exciting because they are
are relatively easy to collect in
comparison to blood which requires
um needles and typically a trained
person to to collect a blood sample
uh last but not least we showed that you
could develop uh assays to detect new
sequences really quickly uh within a
week and that required uh just a little
bit of
um you know design waiting for nucleic
acids to be synthesized and then
ultimately
all right so fast forward a little bit
to early 2020 we realized that there was
still a lot more work to do the
technology we had developed you know
initially was really exciting but
um in light of the covid-19 pandemic we
realized that this was testing that
really needed to be performed anywhere
by anyone and so we spent a bunch of
work uh streamlining a bunch of the
steps of the process and in particular
we combined the amplification t7
transcription and detection into a
single reaction
I did a lot of biochemical optimization
to achieve this kind of single step
Sherlock reaction
um
in combination with uh a rapidly
um with a rapid method for scent for
viral inactivation that we developed uh
called Hudson and so the workflow
overall starts with this 10 minute viral
inactivation followed by this sort of
single step Sherlock protocol
and then ends with either a visual
readout as I showed you on the previous
slide or with a fluorescent in tube
readouts that you can directly see
whether or not something is present
without needing to open the tube which
could cause potential you know
contamination
and so on the right side of this slide
I'm just showing you a few examples of
what that looks like on on patient
samples and you can see we're indeed
able to differentiate positive samples
from negative samples quite nicely using
both of our readouts overall this method
performed pretty well it was about 90 as
sensitive as PCR it had perfect
specificity and it took about 50 minutes
from start to finish
but the virus continued to to to evolve
and so we needed to step our game up and
indeed over the past two years we
developed a method called shine version
two which allows us to do at home
um covid test 19 testing
um and the way that works is we've
further simplified the sample processing
to a five minute ambient temperature uh
protocol we fully lyophilized all of the
reagents so that they could easily be
reconstituted by just adding um buffer
uh to to to rehydrate everything
um
and then finally
um we optimized these uh detection and
and and readout uh to make it even
simpler for someone to perform
we then compared this method to the
state of the art a simple method for
covid-19 testing which is rapid antigen
tests now a number of you may be
familiar uh with those tests having used
them uh perhaps to to test your yourself
at a variety of different times so so
these tests are really great they take
only 15 to 30 minutes to perform but
unfortunately they're not super
sensitive and as I'm showing you on this
graph
our shine technology is about 50 times
more sensitive
um than those tests and we did this by
taking a set of 96 uh patient samples
that we tested using qpcr shine as well
as two uh of the state of the art uh rap
and antigen tests uh the lab at pinex
now as well as a test provided by car
start
and so we're really excited to see this
good performance
one additional thing we also did in that
paper
is we used shine to detect uh SARS CO2
variants of concern and this was
building off of the work I showed you
earlier that showed we could detect
individual mutations as
covid-19 continued to evolve we really
wanted to know kind of how fast were new
variants spreading and so we we now have
Shine assays for a number of different
variants what I'm showing you here on
the slide is just a summary of our
Omicron assay which can differentiate
Omicron positive samples from Delta
samples
and what you can see is that again by
using a pair of crispr rnas and sort of
comparing them we can tell whether or
not a sample contains Omicron as
indicated by the derived or der crispr
RNA coming up more strongly than the ank
or ancestral crispr RNA conversely if a
sample has Delta then the Ang crispr RNA
produces uh that that stronger band
um compared to the derived and so that's
a way that we can differentiate
Omicron from Delta
we also did a bit of work where we
showed that you can actually incubate
the reaction using body heat in your
armpit to achieve completely equipment
free detection because
recall that the sample processing
happens in ambient temperature the only
step that we really need is that
temperature that control temperature
incubation is the actual you know
detection reaction itself now there's
still you know quite a bit of work to be
done here to make this as simple as a
rapid antigen test you may have caught
on the earlier slide that it's this
protocol takes about an hour and a half
or so from start to finish so it's not
as fast as a rapid antigen test but it
is more sensitive and it's it's simple
to use and it can detect variants so we
think that there's quite a bit of
utility there
all right
so this sort of really simplified
at-home testing is just one part of the
larger problem here and and so we
separately asked can we actually scale
up Sherlock in order to perform a lot of
multiplexing
and detect many many different targets
in many samples at once
um and this was inspired by work that
our colleagues had done
um showing enzymatic multiplexing um
using different cost 12 and Caster pin
orthologs
so the way that we do this and this is
an another method we developed called
Carmen
um is is by miniaturizing the reactions
themselves and so what we do is we take
individual
um samples that have been Amplified
using PCR
um or detection mixes that contain cash
13 the crispr RNA and And the reporter
and we put we make emulsions
containing those different samples or
those different detection mixes
now each emulsion
has a color code which is basically a
unique ratio of fluorophores that allows
us to tell apart
um one sample from another from another
or one detection mix from another from
another
and it turns out that we can
differentiate about a thousand different
color codes using ratios of different
standard fluorophores and so with those
tricks in mind what we can then do is
take our Emulsion and load it into this
microwell array
which you can basically think of as a a
sort of plastic chip that contains tens
to hundreds of thousands of really
really small Wells
now each well is designed to accommodate
a pair of droplets from the Emulsion and
what that means is that you're going to
get all of the pairwise combinations of
sample and detection mix and those are
going to form spontaneously in the
microwell array
and so what we can then do once we've
loaded all of our droplets from the
Emulsion onto the array because we can
image the array using a fluorescent
microscope
and that will just tell us you know
which samples are where and which
detection mixes are where
then we can merge neighboring droplets
within a well by applying electricity to
the sample
um
which then allows us to initiate the
detection reactions
and then we can monitor the fluorescent
readout much like we would for a
standard Sherlock reaction again using a
fluorescent microscope to see which of
these droplets uh and really more
specifically which Wells are turning on
over time
um and by analyzing all of this data in
combination we can then figure out you
know which crispr rnas were actually
turning on and we're detecting
um individual sequences
and that yields this really
comprehensive Matrix where we've now
tested every single sample for the
presence of a whole panel of different
pathogens of Interest
and by determining where the positivity
results we can sort of tell you you know
which samples are infected uh with which
pathogen
all right
so we've done a fair bit of work with
that method I'm just going to summarize
that here on the next slide
we developed a 169 Plex human Associated
virus panel that can detect all sorts of
different pathogens simultaneously and
it works really well as summarized by
this ginormous heat map where basically
the diagonal of the heat map consists of
all of the on-target detection that we
would hope to see and there's very
little off-target off diagonal activity
about 95 of the designs here work well
after just one round of optimization and
that was really encouraging to see
because it suggests this method can
really work well in a multiplexed
fashion without creating a lot of false
positive results or anything like that
we also developed an influenza subtyping
panel that can differentiate the
different influenza subtypes so you may
be familiar with things like H1N1 or
H3N2 that typically infect humans
um we built a comprehensive panel that
can detect H1 through h16 and N1 through
nine
um and and those panels work quite well
again on synthetic samples as shown by
by the heat Maps we also tested this out
on a series of clinical samples and
showed that they fell really nicely into
the two groups that we would expect H1N1
and H3N2
and so this was just some really nice
validation
um that Carmen works well
again this is where Carmen stood as of
early 2020
um and so when the pandemic hit we
realized we had to really try and scale
this method up and and take it to the
next level
and so for the last part of the talk I'm
going to talk about microfluidic Carmen
or M Carmen which is basically taking
the same principles of Carmen that I had
told you about earlier but implementing
them using a commercially available
microfluidic platform
and this basically consists of a
microfoidic ship called an integrated
fluidic circuit or IFC that contains a
number of input ports for samples or
different detection mixes and so it lets
us test either 96 by 96 or 192 by 24
different samples by crispr rnas
um to achieve a very similar result to
to the original permanent technology
that I outlined earlier the advantage
here is that this is a lot simpler to
set up because the equipment like the
instrument automates a lot of this
process we don't need to color code we
don't need to dropletize
um and the readout is much more
automated over time because of the
microfluidics in the system
and so using Adam Carmen we were able to
very rapidly develop a respiratory virus
panel for 21 different respiratory
viruses than I'm outlining here and you
can see with very good performance
across the board and very little
cross-reactivity
um
we then took a subset of this panel so
we took nine of the viruses and really
streamlined the workflow for those nine
most clinically relevant viruses by
automating various steps of the process
and again further streamlining things so
that we ended up with a workflow that
took about four hours from start to
finish this is in contrast the original
Carmen which took about eight hours and
so we tried to really streamline things
as much as possible and the reason that
we did that is because we wanted a
method that could be used in a Clinical
Laboratory
um where you know hundreds or thousands
of samples might be processed in a day
and if you're doing you know things at
that level you really need things to
work as well as possible
um and to minimize the amount of human
labor involved because that's you know
where mistakes can get made and and you
know in a clinical lab you really want
to make sure that every result that
you've got
um has a lot of Integrity behind it and
so
we spent uh quite a bit of time
um you know optimizing this workflow of
the respiratory virus panel
um and then tested it out both to
determine the analytical limit of
detection which I'm kind of showing you
here this involves basically taking
um viral seed stocks at different
concentrations and then diluting them
down to the lowest levels that you can
detect consistently
um and at least 19 out of 20 technical
replicates and you can see here that
across the board we do very well
um in many cases we're at or below one
copy per microliter of input which is
about as low as you can go
um for for seven of the nine viruses on
the panel so that was super exciting and
really nice to see
we then performed a clinical validation
of our panel uh using a series of
patient samples as well as contrived
samples provided by Partners
um at MGH where we performed all of the
testing and so here what we did was we
just compared the performance of our
respiratory virus panel to Gold Standard
nucleic acid detection assays that are
routinely used for clinical diagnosis
and what we're looking for here is how
well do these methods agree on a series
of
30 positive and 30 negative samples for
each of the viruses tested
and what we saw
is that for nine sorry eight of the nine
viruses on the panel we were above 95
agreement between the two assays
which is the threshold set by the FDA
for uh for performance and so that was
really encouraging and suggested to us
that the the performance of the panel
was really Exquisite and it was ready
for use in more clinical settings
as I mentioned earlier viral detection
is really only one half of the picture
and we noticed you know here that
as many people did that SARS code 2
continued to evolve over time and that's
really challenging
um from a detection perspective so in
order to really track the the evolution
of the virus over time we developed a
variant identification panel or VIP we
think it's a very important panel
um
and the way that this works is basically
by using a pair of primers to amplify
the entire Spike Gene and what this lets
us do is then use combinations of crispr
rnas to detect a series of individual
mutations in the spike Gene about 20 or
so
um
and so we picked a series of mutations
kind of shown in the heat map and what's
really interesting about this is that
you can see that each different SARS
Cove 2 variant seed stock that we tested
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta and Epsilon has a
unique signature on the panel so for
example you know all of those variants
contain the d614g mutation which
occurred very early on you know during
sarscope 2 evolution
however a variety of these mutations are
specific to one lineage or are found in
just a pair of them and this really
illustrates again the power of our
multiplexed approach because if we were
just using one or two of these mutations
it would be impossible to tell apart all
of these different variants but with
this multiplexed approach we can really
tell
um uh one variant apart from another
with exquisite detail as I get into on
the next slide and so here we just
tested a series of 101 patient samples
that contain Alpha Beta Gamma Delta or
Epsilon
and we compared our variant
identification panel or the VIP with
Next Generation sequencing which is
really the gold standard for nucleic
acid detection
and what we saw here was that only three
of the 101 samples were discordant so
about 97 agreement between the two
passes
um and what I'm showing you on the right
half of this slide is a breakdown on a
permutation basis again pointing out
that with any one of these mutations it
would be hard to achieve even like a 20
or 30 percent uh variant calling
capability it's really only by combining
all of these mutations together that
we're able to achieve a good performance
all right so that is where
um the identifications panel stood late
last year
um
however a new variant emerged uh called
Omicron and Omicron produced a unique
signature on the VIP
um
I can't understate how important that
result was because we didn't have to
change a single thing about the design
of our panel uh from day one it was
ready to go to detect a newly emerging
variant that had a ton of mutations in
it
um and so we were then able to very
rapidly attract Omicron as it first
spread across the Harvard campus and I'm
showing you some data here from early
December of last year where you can see
over the course of just a week or so
from about December 6th or 7th to
December 14th or 15th the variant goes
from you know very low levels
um to nearly all of the samples that are
being tested at Harvard and conversely
Delta which is shown in the darker color
is decreasing over time as well
um so this is a really poignant example
of how this panel could be used in a
real world setting uh where all of a
sudden a new variant emerged and very
rapidly spread through the population
um and of course what starts at Harvard
tends to spread to other places and so
then in collaboration with the
Department of Public Health in the state
of Massachusetts we were able to very
rapidly track Omicron as it spread uh
throughout the state
and what I'm showing you here is
basically the proportion of cases that
were Omicron positive over time the Open
Circles are our m carbon data that was
captured more or less in real time so
the state would send us samples that had
tested positive the previous day and the
next day we would return them the Carmen
data in contrast the full circles
represent what you could do with Next
Generation sequencing and there's an
unfortunate lag of about a week or so
because it takes a while to collect
process and analyze the sequencing data
in contrast to carbon which is a really
fast and simple protocol and so as a
result of this sequencing lag you really
aren't able to capture the Dynamics of a
quickly spreading variant
um but with this crispr-based approach
we were really able to and that was very
useful to the state
now if we fast forward to January what
you can see is that by January 1st you
know Omicron was basically omnipresent
throughout the state of Massachusetts
um and indeed the data from both m
carbon and sequencing basically had very
good agreement with one another
now we weren't able to use m carbon on
every single sample collected in the
state of Massachusetts so the reason why
there are some slight discrepancies in
the prevalences measured by the two
methods is because they're using
different sample sets um so it's not a
one-to-one comparison here but the point
is that the correlation is is quite good
and really
um again goes to show how well the
methods agreed with with one another we
tested over 2 000 samples
um as Omicron spread throughout the
state and we saw that over 99 of the
time you know uh M Carmen agreed with
sequencing in terms of uh which variant
was present
all right so now I'd just like to wrap
up real quick and and and revisit
um this graphic that I showed at the
beginning
um so again we're working on on assays
with with faster turnaround time
um and that can can do more and more
tests
um and both shine and Carmen are really
trying to move us up and to the right on
this graph
um now as we wrap up I would just like
to acknowledge a really large team of
people who are responsible for the work
um including a number of people whose
names are involved on this slide as well
as my new Lab at Princeton uh
collaborators and funding
um and one last pitch that we are
recruiting postdocs in my lab um so if
you're interested in joining my lab uh
please do feel free to reach out thank
you